As the fighting in Sudan
enters its six week,
it is forcing
hundreds of thousands of people
to flee their homes,
according to a new report
from the United Nations,
the International Organization
for Migration.
More than 1 million
people have been displaced in Sudan.
More than 300,000
have fled to neighboring countries.
80,000 of them to Chad
or CNN correspondent
Larry Madowo reports.
For us tonight, it's a report
you'll only see on CNN
The kids cry constantly.
They'd always look weary of war.
The pained faces here,
a reminder of the horrors
that drove them out of Sudan.
To work at this refugee camp.
Across the border in Chad,
sadness stalks almost everyone.
As fighting
intensified in Sudan's western
Darfur region,
they had to run or risk getting killed.
Kubra Abdalla left
so suddenly
that her son got lost in the chaos.
I know my brother is still back there.
I heard he was injured.
I was forced to come to Chad to seek
safety.
Would you go back to Sudan
and another game?
No, no.
The only reason I will go back
is to bring my child and my brother here.
There has been too much
insecurity for too long
because of decades of conflict in Sudan.
Many of these refugees
had already been internally displaced
several times.
Must Charlotte is 22,
but hasn't known a permanent home
for most of her life.
I has highly engaged
I'm worried
about all the people we left behind,
especially my mother,
who could not cross the border.
I keep asking myself
how I can get out to Chad.
I noticed that
mostly women and children here.
Where are the men from? Sudan.
We know
the men told us to take the children
and cross the border
so they can stay behind
to defend themselves.
And our property if necessary.
The U.N.
Refugee Agency says close to 90%
of new arrivals
in Chad from Sudan
are women and children.
Many so traumatized,
but they will need
a lot of support to heal.
We had expected to meet refugees
as they arrived
in the border town of Katherine,
right across from Sudan.
But just before we arrived,
it was hit by a rocket.
That is why refugees are being moved away
from border towns
to places like this in Gaza.
CNN traveled with U.S.
aid administrators
Samantha Power to Eastern Chad.
The U.S.
is giving more than $100 million
to support the over
1 million people displaced by the war
across Sudan.
And in neighboring countries.
We met one woman whose
I had been gouged,
basically with somebody
just attacking her.
And she's seeking
medical care here in Chad.
Horrific violence
which triggers
for so many of these people.
Also memories of previous
horrific violence.
It's a full circle moment for her.
She was in Chad in 2004
writing in The New Yorker
about Sudanese
civilians fleeing the Janjaweed
militia in Darfur.
You talk to them,
you feel like you're in a time warp
because they're describing Janjaweed
coming in with their knives
and their machetes.
Killing people, raping women.
Is it's a real for you being here,
hearing these stories
when you heard them
20 years ago as a reporter?
Well, I feel lucky this time, at least,
to be working at USAID,
the big development humanitarian agency.
At least there's something I can do.
But fundamentally, there is no substitute
for the root causes getting addressed
for these two warring
generals to put their own
power grabs aside
and put the interests of these people
who are fleeing, sometimes
for the fifth time in their lives.
Chad, one of the world's
poorest countries,
had about 400,000
Sudanese refugees
before this latest surge.
We need to collectively, you know,
work with
all the
actors in support to
the government of Chad
to ensure that,
you know, resources
are mobilized
to address
the urgent needs of the of the refugees
today.
These are the innocent victims
of a deadly power struggle in Sudan.
And the camera,
the poor and most vulnerable
who have no way to go.
Just another chapter
in a life of hardship.
And a son this Sudan conflict has quickly
spilled over
into a regional refugee crisis.
These latest statistics
from the UN are significant.
1.3 million people displaced
mostly in Sudan, but over 3000
have crossed into neighboring countries
like Egypt and Chad.
The refugees
I met in eastern Chad
don't live in comfortable conditions.
The heat alone.
It's more than 110 degrees Fahrenheit.
They live in these
makeshift structures in the desert,
but they still prefer
that it's safer for them than in Darfur,
where they've come from.
So many of them have been displaced,
sometimes up to five times.
And they don't care
which of the two warring
generals in Sudan wins this.
They just want peace.
They want the same things.
You and I want
a chance at a dignified life.
And they will go back
for whoever can deliver that for them
Anderson.
Larry, media reporting. Thank you.